completely opposite what is going on for
joe biden which has been very good
things are going disastrously for the
failed former president donald trump who
is desperate desperate to claim
innocence and try to get himself out of
all sorts of legal trouble
and potentially justify another
presidential run in 2024 donald trump
had a historic meltdown yesterday on
truth social declaring himself innocent
declaring himself innocent and you have
to see these posts just a sort of
diarrhea of the post donald trump
starting quote even though i am as
innocent as a person can be and despite
my campaign being spied on by the
radical left the fisa court being lied
to and defrauded and all of the many
hoaxes and scams that were illegally
placed on me by very sick and demented
people and without even mentioning the
many crimes of joe and hunter biden all
revealed in great detail in the laptop
from hell
it looks more and more like the fake
news media is pushing hard for the
sleaze to do something that should not
be done
that's an insane message
it is nuts that a former president typed
out that message and posted it publicly
there are probably 10 lies and
distortions in that short message
and by the way trump saying that he is
as innocent as anyone has ever been to
me suggests he's guilty now this isn't a
court of law i'm not suggesting trump be
denied due process this is the court of
common sense many things the more
strongly trump claims a the more likely
the opposite of a is likely to be true
uh and trump's kind of interesting in
that he's very direct in that sense many
politicians will equivocate and they'll
play semantics or they'll kind of
massage facts or distract and muddy the
waters when trump's guilty he'll just
come out and say i'm innocent
that's been the theme trump continuing
to post quote joe biden said he knew
nothing about the break-in of mar-a-lago
or the greatest political attack in the
history of the u.s does anybody really
believe this now there is no evidence
biden knew anything and of course it
wasn't a break-in it was a search
warrant signed by the attorney general
okayed by trump's own fbi director
appointee
and a judge signed off on it so again
all lies trump continuing quote the
radical left democrat prosecutors are
illegally trying to circumvent for
purely political gain the presidential
records act under which i have done
absolutely nothing wrong it cannot be
circumvented for me or any other
president they illegally raided my home
untrue and took things that should not
have been taken untrue they even broke
into my safe and unthinkable act well
the safe was listed in the search
warrant everything was perfectly legal
trump then resorting to just tweeting or
i'm sorry not tweeting truthing in all
caps presidential records act
trump then posting quote the justice
department and fbi are quote leaking at
levels never seen before and i did
nothing wrong i think trump's brain is
leaking at levels never seen before and
then donald trump also putting out a
statement which is crazy which says joe
biden and the radical left democrats
have just orchestrated another election
enhancing money grab this time to the
tune of 300 billion dollars and just
like i predicted it's coming right out
of the pocket of the working class
americans who are struggling the most
crippling inflation unaffordable energy
prices and war
all things that should have never
happened but if that wasn't enough now
americans are bailing out college
administrators who fleeced students and
who opted for degrees there was no way
they could afford
america is a nation in decline and the
cliff into oblivion is within sight stop
voting for democrats make america great
again i miss a clear very inspirational
message from donald trump it is not
normal for anybody it when your neighbor
flips out on social media like this it's
cause for alarm this is a failed former
president doing it and it's incredibly
humiliating
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the u.s alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one american uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required
put an end to that right now with real
paper the best part is the stuff is
really great it's just normal soft
toilet paper real paper loves the david
pakman show they're giving my audience
thirty percent off your first order and
free shipping when you go to real paper
dot com slash pacman and use the code
pacman at checkout the link is down
below